venez découvrir les résidents d'elmen
City
les aériens ont souvent la tête dans les
nuages
sont un peu fleur bleue
les aquatiques n'hésitent jamais à se
mouiller
[Musique]
flamboyants pas de commande on est tout
feu tout flamme
[Musique]
cette boutique est le rêve de notre
famille et un jour elle sera toi mais
nous cohabitons grâce à une règle d'or
mélange pas
en plus
[Musique]
donc tu n'es jamais sorti de Fire Town
désolé on est pas compatible
mon père te ferait bouillir à feu vif
mais de quel droit les gens peuvent te
dire ce côté censé faire ou pas
on se demande à quoi servent ces
grillages
j'ai l'impression que tu as changé
quelque part
j'ai toujours voulu faire la fierté de
mon père mais je ne me suis jamais
demandé ce que je rêvais de faire
tout est dans cela arrête ils sont trop
chaud cela j'adore
[Musique]
il se régale